it's never about policy anymore it's
actually
right i mean america right now is the
johnny depp amber heard trial
i i really like people are so obsessed
with this and i feel like there's
two reasons and one is because it
absolutely mirrors this country two
parties who absolutely hate each other
i mean if if you said the things that
amber or johnny depp said to amber heard
and you asked doug mastriano in
pennsylvania what about this uh would
you like to the democrats corpse
absolutely he'd say
that is exactly what i'd like to do with
him yeah it's it sounds like it's about
ending careers her career his career i
think they both will have a career
afterwards but it not might not be
interesting
he will might take off she will not yeah
he she will always she will be in
the bad amber
that's nice
well a couple things he has what i call
f me money fu money is good but f me
money meaning he
can spend a ton of money destroying
himself and still come out the other
side but say adam it's hbo oh sorry
you money's gonna me money but
i'm not interested in those two i'm
interested in the throngs of people who
are outside the courthouse every day
yeah first off
i want those people rounded up
i do you know they're all on disability
getting money from the government
they tell their boss i can't come in and
do my computer data entry job because of
my back i'll be out for a few more
months and they're up there with a
bedazzled cardboard sign hopping up and
down who are these people there's
welfare dads in there there's cheater
moms there's welfare
round those people up they're gainfully
they should be gainfully employed
they're evidently employable they're
mobile they're on the they're
enthusiastic i mean they might be paid
extra i'm not no they're not paid extras
they're actually paying money to scalp
their scalpers selling tickets on that
line because it's such a hot ticket but
i must admit you do have one little
point here
because
i go out in the day sometimes i go to a
week off or something i i know why i'm
out in the day but i'm like there's a
lot of people out there yes
it's just a lot like where are you all
going
don't does anyone have a job in
this yes
i mean you're at the mall tuesday at two
o'clock and it's really a jam every time
i go into a starbucks at you know one in
the afternoon the guy's got his
spreadsheets out there and there's three
computers at least he's working yeah but
i'm just saying like i this didn't used
to exist people had a place to go in
this country i don't i don't know who
what are you guys doing here tonight
i'm working
uh
bill yeah no further
you